on attend avec hâte quand même de
pouvoir me dire que j'ai pu une
attestation pour dépasser de 10 km à
partir de mon point de départ
j'ai hâte c'est surtout la l'étape du 19
mai que j'attends avec impatience la
réouverture des cinémas et des terrasses
qui font vraiment bouger de faire bouger
des choses là vient d'arriver sur paris
ça fait deux semaines donc je suis tout
nouveau les 10 km ça me va pour
l'instant mais voilà c'est les terrasses
et les jt que j'attends maintenant oui
bien sûr on va voir des proches parce
que c'est vrai que c'est être restreint
c'est un peu niveau l'asie à 13 cents
niveau là c'est grâce à ça un peu bon
c'est un peu compliqué voix savez dit
lemaître s'est pas beaucoup j'ai palois
est bon c'est un peu dommage que ce soit
maintenant certains comme ça avec tout
ce qu'il faut à ce moment mais bon on
comprend et on fait avec quoi alors pas
vraiment changement de vie mais oui de
pouvoir voir les gens qui sont un peu
plus loin ça va faire du bien
si je dois dire la vérité j'aimerais
qu'il ya aucune restriction de
kilomètres oui là ça va faire du bien
ouais on a hâte ah bah oui très contente
qu'on ait plus de restrictions de
déplacements
personnellement moi ça fait deux mois
que je suis pas rentré voir ma famille
donc là dès que dès que c'est bon bah du
coup à partir de demain le week-end
prochain ou dans les jours à venir on va
retourner voir la famille oui ça fait du
bien de pouvoir se dire que voilà on va
pouvoir bouger s'assouplit de plus en
plus après maintenant ce qu'on espère
surtout c'est la réouverture totale des
bars et des restaurants
eh ben c'est très bien on va pouvoir
bouger retournez voir notre ennemi et
puis puis est souvent restreint tout
simplement on voit toujours quelques
amis en petit comité mais mais oui on va
pouvoir revoir des amis qu'on a pas vu
depuis un certain temps qu'ils étaient
loin notamment donc donc ça va faire du
bien le la fin des 10 km va nous
permettre vraiment de de plus voir nos
proches nos amis etc
donc c'est quelque chose de bénéfique je
trouve les vents mai
et mes amis que j'ai pas vu depuis un
moment qui habite un peu plus loin que
j'habite à 15 kilomètres donc je vais en
profiter pour aller les voir
moi mes parents habitent à paris donc je
les vois mais oui je compte partir en
vacances déjà en juin
donc voila mais j'ai quand même bouger
j'ai bougé ce mois ci même s'il y avait
10km c'est pas très bien mais c'était
pour le travail donc voila mais je suis
assez contente que que les attestations
à que la limite c'est fini parce que
franchement là on n'en peut plus rester
confinés chez nous c'est plus possible
et surtout que nous n'a la fac
enfin moi je suis à la fac et c'est vrai
que travailler toute la journée chez soi
et pas pouvoir partir en week-end ou
quelque chose comme ça franchement
c'était très difficile mais là les
vacances s'annoncent plutôt pas mal ben
moi je suis super heureuse parce que ça
faisait huit mois que j'avais pas pu
venir sur paris et je viens d'arriver du
coup et il enlève cette restriction
c'est super parce que je vais pouvoir
voir ma grand mère qui habite dans le
nord de paris et mon autre grand mère
qui habite en bretagne la semaine
prochaine du coup je suis assez contente
je vous avoue que ça fait plaisir